o Raul meu amigo eu tenho conversa em
cheiro mesmo 15 minutos já foi enterrado
é papo morreu em terror não tem conversa
tivesse escrito filho do cara corre daí
falar gente eu tô vivo os parentes vão
dizer [ __ ] aqui em cima não pode ver
que dá notícia de morte de rica sempre
assim Mário Roberto de Alencastro famoso
cirurgião plástico das Estrelas morre
esta madrugada de infarto miocárdico do
papel de massas hora da morte foi
confirmada às 3:14 da manhã e o corpo
foi velado as 3:45 os parentes já estão
em casa tranquilo de boa do menino
parentes e amigos da família estão de
luto em nos Maldivas o pobre até chegar
os filhos tudo que tem Espanha pelo
Brasil eu não pode enterrar e produzir é
tudo bem hoje em Brasília Honda São
Paulo Honda Manaus Ave Maria só falta o
falecido levantar e falar rapaz eu
soubesse que era assim eu tinha morrido